mind your decisions i'm preshtalwalkar
in this hexagon all sides have the same
length
and opposite sides are parallel the
distances between
opposite sides are equal to 237
195 and 192.
what is the area of the hexagon
i admit i did not solve this problem
the puzzle and its solution were created
by elliott line
editor of mensa's enigma magazine
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try
and when you're ready keep watching to
learn how to solve this problem
[Music]
one way to approach the problem is to
append a right triangle to each side of
the hexagon
first we will extend the top and bottom
opposite sides
such that we construct a purple and a
green right triangle
the shorter legs will be parallel to
each other and the longer legs will be
co-linear
and they will intersect at a vertex of
the hexagon
the two longer legs will have a total
length of 237
next we will append a congruent purple
triangle
and we will append a congruent green
triangle
for the remaining two sides we will
extend the longer leg of this purple
right triangle
and construct a blue triangle finally we
will extend
the longer leg of the green right
triangle and we will construct another
right triangle
and notice the two right triangles we've
constructed will be congruent to each
other
we again have the distances of the
collinear sides as shown
before we go further let me preview the
final calculation
suppose the hexagon has a side length
equal to x
how could we solve for the area of the
hexagon take a point in the interior
now consider these two triangles let's
say their heights
are a and b we know the areas of these
two triangles will be one half
x times a plus one half x times b
and that's equal to one-half times x
times the quantity a plus b
but we know that a plus b is equal to
237
so the sum of these two areas will be
one-half
multiplied by x multiplied by 237
we can do a similar construction for
these two triangles
and we'll get the sum of their areas
will be equal
to one-half multiplied by x multiplied
by 195.
we finally do the same thing for these
two triangles
and we get that their areas will have a
sum that's equal to one-half
x multiplied by 192. we can factor out
x over 2 and we get that the total area
of the hexagon
is equal to x over 2 multiplied by the
sum of these heights
so all that remains is to solve for x
how are we going to do that
let's go back to our diagram suppose the
long leg of the purple right triangle is
equal to a
and the long leg of the green right
triangle is equal to b
finally suppose this leg of the blue
right triangle is equal to c
we can now set up that a plus b is equal
to 237
a plus c is equal to 195
and finally b plus c is equal to 192
we'll solve this system of equations for
a b and c
one way to do that is to take the sum of
these three equations
we'll get 2 multiplied by the sum of a b
and c
is equal to 624 we divide by 2
to get the sum of a b and c
from here we could take the sum of the
three variables and subtract
the first equation to get that c is
equal to 75
we can then subtract the second equation
to get b
is equal to 117 we then subtract the
third equation
to get a is equal to 120
thus we have values for a b and c
now let's consider x as the side length
of the hexagon
and suppose that we mark the angles as a
b and c in this right triangle
we have x is equal to a divided by the
sine of angle a
in this green right triangle we have x
is equal to b
over the sine of angle b and in this
blue right triangle we have x
is equal to c divided by the sine of
angle c
now let's consider the angles a b and c
notice that they are exterior angles to
this hexagon
because opposite sides are parallel this
exterior angle will be equal to a
this exterior angle be equal to b and
this exterior angle will be equal to c
therefore we have two multiplied by the
sum of the angles a b and c
will be equal to 360 degrees that's
because the sum of exterior angles
will be equal to 360 degrees we divide
both sides by two
to get a plus b plus c is equal to 180
degrees
therefore a b and c can be angles
in a triangle because the sum of angles
in a triangle is equal to 180 degrees
from here we can scale this triangle in
such a way
that the side opposite angle a has
exactly the length
of 120 which is equal to a
because we've derived this relationship
we can use the law of sines
that we can get the side opposite angle
b
will have exactly the length of 117
which is equal to b
and the side opposite angle c will have
a length that's equal
to 75 which is lowercase c
from here we can just consider these
equations
using el kashi's law of cosines we can
solve that a squared is equal to b
squared plus c squared minus 2bc
cosine of angle a we can use this
equation to solve for the cosine of
angle a
we know the values of sides a b and c
and we substitute those in to get the
cosine of angle a
is equal to 7 over 25 we can then solve
for the sine of angle a
and we get this is equal to 24 over 25
then we know that x is equal to a
divided by the sine of angle a
we can substitute in the value for a and
the sine of angle a
and we get that x is equal to 125
we can then go back to our procedure for
solving for the area
and remember that the formula was the
following
we simply need to substitute x is equal
to 125
and evaluate and we get the area of the
hexagon
is equal to 39 000. amazing
thanks for making mind your decisions
one of the best channels on youtube
see you next episode as we continue our
quest
to solve the world's problems one video
at a time
[Music]
you